هذه يبقى في نظره نظره للناس الطبقات اللي
هي معدومه زي حالاتنا
[موسيقى]
موجوده بس للاسف هي بره سوق
مستنيين جزء بس من الاستقرار عشان السيوله
يعني تتضخ في السوق بالنسبه لي كان محطوط
كاسيناريو اساسي لعده اسباب اولها استقرار
سعر الصرف ثانيا زياده تدفقات النقد
الاجنبي ثالثا استمرار تباطؤ وتيره ارتفاع
الفائده في امريكا بالتحديد زي ما شفنا
هذا الاسبوع
ورابعا ويمكن دي من اهم العوامل هي
الزياده الضخمه في سعر الفائده في مصر
العام الماضي اللي وصلت بشكل تراكمي ل 800
نقطه اساس او 8%
بعد اتفاق صندوق النقد وكمان التقرير
الاخير اللي صدر عن الصندوق اللي بيقول
بوضوح ان نظام سعر الصرف في مصر بدا
بالفعل يتحول لنظام اكثر مرونه فبتوقع
استقرار سعر الصرف عنده 31 في 20 23
كمتوسط العام كله طبعا ده مش معناه ان مش
هيكون فيه تذبذبات على المدى القصير
[موسيقى]